how do you show that the world is ready
for a black
captain america by acknowledging that
the world probably isn't ready
and doing it anyways
[Music]
we've reached the end of the second
disney plus show set
in the mcu the falcon and the winter
soldier
which on the surface is a far more
straightforward affair especially when
compared to
something like wanda vision which was
deliberately disorientating right from
the onset
am i right but one really should be
careful not to confuse straightforward
with simple
or with lacking in depth because there's
plenty going on with the themes and the
cultural details in this
to be worth taking a deeper look at it
as a completed piece of work
and just in case you didn't take the
hint that is actually your warning that
i will not
be holding back on discussing spoilers
let's not dilly dally
and get to it
[Music]
dilly dally how old am i ah
okay anyway moving on so ultimately the
show's basic function within the world
of the greater marvel cinematic universe
is exactly what a lot of folks expected
it's the journey of sam wilson
earning the title of captain america now
part of why i was expecting this to
happen here is because
well things like cultural acceptance of
a black captain america the weight of
legacy and the expectation on both sam
and bucky and sam's own self-doubt about
taking up the shield
aren't impossible to explore in a
feature film
it would have been very difficult to do
those ideas any kind of justice in
two hours while still having room for
the action focus that moviegoers are
going to expect
giving those ideas six hours both space
to breathe and to also be able to have
the action scenes without feeling
overstuffed it not only benefits this
story
but it also means that when captain
america four happens
it has been confirmed that the series
creator malcolm spellman
and show runner delon moussan are
writing the script for that
sam is going to be able to hit the
ground running already settled into the
role and not have to be bogged down on
his big screen debut
with this lingering baggage it's a
win-win all around
and uh it's also a pretty great way to
make sure that the show feels
essential even though people who skip it
can safely assume sam got comfortable in
the role since the events of end game
when they see him in captain america for
red wings revenge or
whatever they end up calling it yeah
i see you kevin feige but while just
serving to
connect the dots between this how does
it feel
[Music]
like it's someone else's and this
[Music]
may have been the utilitarian function
of the show
they could have gotten away with just
stringing along action sequences in a
few
am i ready conversations but instead the
show
took the occasion of not only sam
self-doubt but buckies as well
to build something more
[Music]
first i want to take a little time to
examine the characters of the show both
pre-existing and newly introduced
sam and bucky are easily the most firmly
established coming
into this whole thing despite both
having been relegated to supporting
roles in the films
but part of the fun is they don't really
have that much of an established dynamic
with each other
at the start of this thing so a lot of
their early encounters
are built on tension which makes for a
strong starting dynamic
and also gives them somewhere to go as
trust is built
over the course of the show they also
have their own individual journeys as
well
sam makes the initial choice to
relinquish the shield and then has to
deal with the events that follow that
while trying to get his feet under him
in a world he's been absent from for
five years
when that world wasn't really doing much
to accommodate him even before that
it helps that much of his personal
struggle is brought down to something as
tangible as just trying to keep the
family boat
allowing the ways in which he struggles
day to day to not become
too abstract or broad meanwhile
bucky is still trying to recover from
decades
of being the winter soldier hydra's
mental programming might be gone but he
still carries the weight of those
actions
and he's slowly chipping away at that
sense of guilt
through therapy and reaching out to the
people he's hurt both of which
he does with some reluctance because
because he's bucky so the two are both
on distinct
journeys of self-acceptance and finding
ways to move forward which are
thematically linked but logistically
differentiated enough
to not feel redundant then we have john
walker aka captain america briefly
aka u.s agent now i'm going to dig a bit
more into this guy
down the line but for now can we just
appreciate that when he first shows up
in the suit
he had what might be the most punchable
face ever put on
screen and i mean that in the best way
because
everything about the image of someone
other than steve rogers in that outfit
should feel wrong
the easy thing to do after that would
have been to just lean into the innate
hate ability and make him a flat out
jerk
but instead the start of episode 2
gives us background and shading to john
even though he will ultimately prove
just how unworthy of the shield he
is the thing to remember about john
walker's failings
is that they aren't his alone with the
background we're given
there really can't be any doubt that jon
has been a good soldier
but what he didn't understand and what
his superiors failed to prepare him for
was the fact that captain america can't
be just
a soldier not even a good one john
didn't understand that
and if his superiors did they never
bothered to tell him though
i suspect they didn't understand that
either now like i said
we'll come back to this guy so go ahead
stick a pin in it
but i want to note now that he ends up
being
the first of four characters who fall
into
a gray area between hero and villain
for various reasons speaking of gray
area
how about zemo the i would argue
underappreciated villain of civil war
the show does a dang impressive job
of making him fun to have around without
undercutting the basic beliefs that
caused him to be in conflict with the
avengers in the first place
at his core zemo fundamentally believes
that
no one should have the kind of power
that superheroes possess
the desire to become a superhuman cannot
be separated from supremacists that
deals
and while that puts him in inherent
conflict with sam and bucky
it also makes sense that he'd align with
them to prevent the creation
of more super soldiers in the future
their immediate goals are complementary
so into the fray he goes with zemo never
missing a chance to reiterate his thesis
that
heroes think they are above other people
i don't suppose any of you bothered
visiting the memorial
of course not why would you then there's
carly and the flag smashers which
was where i was actually kind of
terrified that the show was going to
face plant
and while i'm not without a few
reservations i think the show ultimately
managed to ride that
extremely fine line of validating what
they were fighting
for while condemning their methods now
on surface that sounds like an easy
enough thing to do
just have a character with credibility
with the audience go
well they're fighting for a good cause
but we have to
stop them just do that it's all good
right
not exactly and especially not in a
world we live in now
where people marching to protest the
epidemic of black citizens shot by
police are told by white people on tv
and in government
that they're going about this all wrong
and need to be forcibly stopped from
even trying to bring attention
to the issue oh oh
maybe maybe i should have mentioned
we're gonna be doing a politics
in this video and if that caught you off
guard
then you really were not paying
attention to the show that we're talking
about
stick a pin in the flag smashers for now
and uh speaking of politics
how about isaiah bradley first of all
props to the mcu for bringing his
storyline in
a black super soldier experimented on
and then hidden
from the world and i
really hope that you don't need me
to tell you that black people's bodily
autonomy being violated for research in
america
has very much been a thing but if you
need a crash course you can start by
looking up the tuskegee syphilis study
and then maybe wash it down with a side
of henrietta lacks
and realize that would be skimming the
surface
at best but by breaking in somebody like
isaiah
and giving him a backstory of
experimentation exploitation and
cover-up
this helps re-ground this entire
fictional universe in real world history
or at least a variant of same
because when we've seen heroes in this
world return from five years of
non-existence to help defeat
a giant purple space chin wielding magic
rocks then it's
probably a good idea to bring things
back down to earth if you're gonna do a
story like this
and making clear that the mcu's cultural
history mirrors
our own oh that'll just about do it the
show also makes the point
flatly unmissable by what happens right
after sam meets isaiah
but go ahead and stick a pin in that for
now too
the other character i want to highlight
is going to largely be in the interest
of this not being a non-stop gushing
session
that's uh sharon carter another one of
the gray characters and she was
fine i mean look the performance worked
but the character was one of the few
things that felt more like an eye on
future projects than really adding much
to this one
and i think pushing the power broker
revelation to the last episode
kind of put more weight on it than it
could really support
not to mention that it also gave the
time for basically the entire viewing
audience to figure it out first
but unlike one division there wasn't
really a mystery element that the show
was going to make or break on so this
doesn't matter
that much also i suppose the contessa
similarly feels more like a future setup
but i'm inclined to be a little bit
kinder to that since her proper
introduction to the mcu
was supposed to be in black widow you
know the film that got delayed because
of the
global panini so this was intended to
play as a
nod rather than be her actual
introduction
but those are the players and a few
bullet points
so let's take a look at the story that
they were used to tell in the themes
that they were used to explore
[Music]
the very idea of a black man carrying
not only the symbol of captain america
but a proxy representation of the entire
nation is an inherently politically
loaded notion
and the single worst thing that the mcu
could have done
would have been to act like sam's race
it's just no big deal
but this show recognizes and grapples
with the political implications both
head on and symbolically take that scene
from the very first episode the one at
the bank where sam is rejected from
getting
to refinance loans because of what
ultimately amounts to bad credit
now the logistics are specific to the
mcu not having
any kind of income history for five
years due to the blip but the practical
upshot is extremely real world
the nation's wealth is
disproportionately withheld
from people of color and the reasons for
that are legion with
just as many justifications from the
people who control most of the funds
justifications often just as
unreasonable as
i mean you didn't exist for five years
which is too bad but
then there's really nothing i can do to
help i'm truly sorry
let's go ahead and take out one of those
pins and talk about
the all too real scene that happens
right after sam
meets isaiah where he and bucky are
approached by police officers
who come in viewing sam as a potential
threat but not bucky
and it's important that this scene
happens when and where it does
because both sam and the audience have
just found out about the
horrid injustice carried out against
isaiah and then we get a scene
paralleling so many real world incidents
and it makes it abundantly clear that
this is
still happening two white cops enter a
black neighborhood to confront a black
man in front of the house of an older
black man who was deeply wronged by this
country
look this show is not subtle but nor
does it need to be
it doesn't do anybody any good with a
show like this
to leave wiggle room where people could
think that
you know maybe racial politics aren't
really meant to be that big a part of it
but the show isn't without the extension
of an olive branch or two because in
addition to the unjust treatment of
black people
in a way that directly mirrors our own
reality the show
also offers up a metaphorical stand-in
to further expand the point and that's
basically the role
of carly and the flag smashers and what
they stand for
so let's go ahead take out another one
of those pins and talk about the
functional antagonists
for the show the flag smashers look back
on the time after the snap when the
world had come together
by necessity borders came down
restrictions went away
because it was truly all hands on deck
on a global scale
but that meant not only did everyone
have to pitch in but everybody benefited
there was very little value in the old
systems that kept people down
and isolated because everybody was
needed and when half the planet goes
missing
that's going to redefine the value of
everybody who's still here
but then everyone who was lost came back
and now it's time to
get back to normal with all the problems
that entails
we can't let the same [ __ ] who are
put back in power after the blip win
we got a glimpse of how things could be
now let me be clear it's not that the
flag smashers viewed the time when half
the world was gone as somehow idyllic
but that catastrophe forced progress in
so many areas
and now it was all poised to backslide
their mission gained
i think probably unintended significance
in the wake of what's gone on in the
past year
just to pick a single example many
americans have been pleading for decades
for the ability to perform their jobs
from home
whether it be working parents unable to
afford daycare commuters unable to
afford vehicle maintenance or people
with physical or medical conditions
that make commuting or travel or just
being around that many other people
difficult or impossible
many have been saying that the standard
of employers forcing employees to
physically come into an office is making
their lives harder
and then suddenly when being grouped
together in buildings on mass became an
atrocious idea
look at that thousands upon thousands of
people were empowered to work from home
something they'd been told before
just wasn't realistic but once this
catastrophe is behind us there is a very
real possibility that this change won't
stick
and going back to normal puts people
back in the same position before
even though it's now been proven that it
doesn't have to be that way that kind of
backslide
is what the flag smashers are fighting
against and it's a cause where it's easy
to understand why people would
sympathize including
sam but as i said they are still
functionally the antagonists which
requires that their methods be either
extreme to the point of being
objectively bad things that nobody
should be doing
or are in some way undermining their own
cause and the show
kind of does both now as i said i was
really nervous because the risk here
was accidentally sending the message
that real world
and depression movements are using the
wrong
tactics i do think the show largely
avoided crossing that line though
they did step right up to it at points
you're killing innocent people they're
not innocent they're roadblocks in my
journey and i kill them again if i have
to
wow no no no i didn't mean it like that
you tricked me into sounding like like
what
i'm not your enemy i agree with your
fight
i just can't get with the way you're
fighting it but part of why i think the
show got away with it despite scenes
like that
is that the group isn't made up of
hardcore mantra spouting fanatics
despite having a clear mantra that is
often repeated
one word one people when carly blows up
a building
there is doubt when she says they may
have to kill hostages
there is hesitation these people aren't
a monolith
they're not a hive mind and not all are
prepared to go as far as carly does
but at the same time there is value in
showing
how far carly is willing to go because
part of extremist action
stems from a perspective that there
truly are no other options
and the show uses carly to illustrate
that pretty well
you're either brilliant or just
hopelessly optimistic
why can't i be a little bit of both no
she sees someone like sam or bucky as
foolish
for not realizing that nothing short of
what she is doing is ever going to work
and she has to believe that because if
she doesn't she would never
be able to rationalize or justify the
things that she's doing
extremists aren't merely psychotics who
want to cause destruction
there are people who cannot believe that
any other tactic
will ever bring about the end result
they want and the strength of that
conviction
is what makes their actions justified at
least to them which is part of why sam's
confrontation with the heads of the
global repatriation council
is vital in the wake of carly's death
because it not only shows those who
sympathize with her that
just maybe something else might work
the only power i have is that i believe
we can do better but it also shows the
grc
that this is a problem that will not end
until the underlying problem is
addressed
until the system is changed yeah
systemic oppression it's a thing you
know can help when trying to stand up to
it
a rallying symbol which brings us to
[Music]
now at the beginning i said that part of
this movie's overall purpose
was to make sam worthy of carrying the
captain america shield
and i should do some clarification on
that because
what the show's actually about is making
sam realize that he was already worthy
of carrying the shield
sam has to prove himself to himself he
has to allow himself to understand the
value
that he brings to the mantle of captain
america and to see what steve
saw in him when he gave sam the shield
at the end of
end game the show does a great job of
tying bucky's fears about himself
into sam's initial rejection of the
shield
that shield that is that is everything
he stood for that is his legacy he gave
you that shield and you threw it away
like it was nothing
so maybe he was wrong about you and if
he was wrong about you then he was wrong
about me
not only does this link the characters
together emotionally
and thematically it's doubly interesting
if you're aware of the fact that in the
comics bucky did actually take up the
mantle of captain america for a time
more so under extenuating circumstances
than any sense that he deserved to have
it like to be fair
but that idea isn't even entertained as
a vague notion here
the idea that bucky might be worthy of
the shield is one that isn't even on his
radar as an option there is no sense of
well that's not going to be sam it
should be me which would have been
the very easy way to get character
conflict between the two
but instead their conflict is more
nuanced and more about
each needing to better understand the
other as a whole
person and doing some kind of should be
you or should be me
forced mentality just wouldn't have
worked as well
now let's go ahead and take out another
one of those pins and contrast those
mentalities with that of john walker
the question of whether or not he's
worthy of carrying the shield doesn't
appear to be
any part of john's thought process he's
a little worried about being able to do
the job
well sure and i don't want to fail them
as i expect he was for every assignment
he ever had but at no point
does he really indicate that he doubts
the idea that he deserves to hear the
shield
just wonders whether or not he'll do it
justice but he doesn't question
whether or not he deserves the chance
and this presumed
worthiness is one of a couple of key
character traits that make him
completely unfit to be captain america
we'll tackle another one in a later
section
but for now let's look at his sense of
entitlement
john never knew steve never knew about
the tough times the hard days or the
difficult choices
and from the outside looking in it can
appear that steve had the
complete respect of basically everybody
and as far as john walker and indeed
most of the world is concerned
steve was captain america
i mean it should be pretty telling that
the us government didn't try to replace
him during the stretch
when he was hiding between the events of
civil war and infinity war
so again from the outside looking in
steve is captain america
captain america is universally respected
or at least
appears to be john becomes captain
america
and he expects that same sense of
universal respect
and on the home front he gets it but
then the first time somebody truly
pushes back on
recognizing his authority this happens
do you know who i am and then after
committing a literal war crime
when made to face consequences for that
action this
happens i under i understand that i
understand that
now even before the episode where that
happened was aired i made a comparison
between john walker and a certain public
figure and for the moment i'm just going
to go ahead and leave this right here
while i have a sip of tea
john's presumption of self-worth leads
to outbursts
and displays of severe entitlement even
after using the symbol of the most
beloved hero in this fictional world
the symbol meant to embody the very best
of the country he has spent his life
defending
to beat a cowering man to death
it never crosses his mind that maybe
he didn't deserve to have that shield in
the first place and maybe somebody
should take it away from him
sam hesitated to take the shield because
he felt the weight
of what it would mean for him to do that
and he and sam
have very different answers to the big
question
of this show
this is far from the only thematic
question that the show grapples with
but it's the one that it opts to pin its
climax on
and it's fitting because it's a question
that incorporates
all of the major players in the story
carly
is fighting for the people discarded and
devalued by the nebulously empowered grc
a quick note while i would have loved
for the show to call out the us more
directly
on some of these issues i at least
appreciate that they put
an aging american white man openly
questioning
do we really need to bother with a vote
at the head of this whole thing
by the end sam is fighting for that same
group
in addition to symbolically fighting for
his family culture
and the place in history of people like
isaiah but he's doing so by less violent
means which puts him into inevitable
conflict with
carly bucky is fighting for a sense of
helping the world instead of harming it
but also for his friends
the memory of steve and his newfound
appreciation of sam
sharon is fighting for power and
influence zemo's
out of the story by then but he was
fighting to uphold his goal of no
more super soldiers and john by the
final episode he's fighting for revenge
he's driven into action by a desire to
enact violent revenge
against carly and yes he does writers
above that but
yeah stick another pin in this guy we're
not dumb with him yet
the question of who is being fought for
and what lines are worth crossing to
do it is what differentiates each of
these characters
and brings them into conflict it's never
as simple as your goal is bad and i must
stop
you and as i said trying to balance your
goal is admirable but your means are
twisted
is really difficult to get right and one
of the big things that helps it work
here
is that sam doesn't just try to stop
carly
he takes up her cause by
different means the prevailing problem
with real world use of that's not how
you should be trying to fix things is
that it is
mostly presented by people who are not
offering
alternate options they're just shouting
no
not like that which only serves to
silence
the voices of protest but sam isn't just
saying this isn't the way and leaving it
at that he
takes the same moral stand that carly
did but is able to offer a path
that carly didn't have access to and
also wasn't prepared to believe in
he is able to simply flatly and
literally
speak truth directly to power you've got
to do better senator
you've got to step up is this a
contrived situation to allow him to do
that so that it happens on a widely
broadcast platform to force the grc to
be held accountable
well yeah but so what the point is he
made his stand he made it firmly
and he made it while carrying the symbol
and mantle that he felt unworthy of
before and he did it in a way that could
not be ignored the fiction of the world
allowed for that to be a way that can't
really be replicated in real life but
the core message
of speaking truth to power as publicly
as possible
and holding that power to account is
just as valid here
as it is in the mcu also let's not kid
ourselves if sam had said those words
privately without cameras on him
he would have been ignored at best if
not immediately stripped of the shield
because he's made it clear that he's not
just going to fall in line when he's
told to
sam is captain america not only because
he fights for the oppressed
but because he fights for a world of
empathy of humanization of acknowledging
where we failed and doing better instead
of pretending that everything's fine
and also by not fighting for those
things
by any means necessary john walker
was never captain america because he
fought for the status quo
he fought for personal glory and he
fought for revenge yeah
yeah i told you i wasn't done with him
[Music]
there's a few things about john walker
that i really
really need to address because these are
aspects that i've
seen read in ways that i harshly
disagree with
now not knowing the writer's minds i am
not about to say that my read is more
accurate
or anything so stupidly declarative but
wow did some people come away from some
of john walker scenes with a totally
different feeling than i did
point the first and i can't believe i
even have to say this one but it
actually got said in a comment on one of
my episode reviews and if a channel as
small as break room of geeks subscribe
there if you haven't
is getting it then i feel it's safe to
assume that it's
out there broadly speaking and that is
the idea that john walker was punished
excessively for
making
i swear i saw this one
mistake so let's
set aside for a moment the fact that his
one
mistake resulted in the death of a human
being who at that point posed no threat
to him
even if we pretend like that isn't a
viciously heinous act
and also ignore the fact that it
shouldn't matter if it only happened
once this is far from his only mistake
now while to be clear that one mistake
was so far as i could find an
understanding i'm not a lawyer
a violation of the geneva convention
something
doesn't have to be illegal to still be
immoral or viewed as a mistake and with
that in mind
what else did this one time captain
america do
well he pocketed and untested and
potentially hazardous material and never
alerted anyone neither superior
nor friend to its existence he then
proceeded to take it himself
for purely selfish reasons which sidebar
remember that steve took the serum to be
able to better protect
people john took it because he felt
disrespected and intimidated
by people who outclassed him in the
field some of whom
weren't even really his enemies they
weren't even super soldier
he refused to own up to his own failings
and objected to disciplinary action
like a spoiled brat after he once again
murdered a man he then attempted to
retain the title
just stripped from him and went out as a
vigilante with the initial motivation
of pure bloody revenge that is a string
of bad decisions compounded by a failure
to recognize them as such
not one mistake
point the second and nobody will ever
convince me otherwise of this
john walker is not redeemed over the
course of this series
now part of my saying that is a personal
long seat of frustration with narratives
that paint redemption is something that
happens
after making one good decision in the
heat of the moment which
i would argue the show doesn't even
really do
but some viewers still seem to feel that
he was in fact redeemed
he's not not here that's not to say that
he's somehow beyond redemption only that
one good deed after a string of bad
choices has to be the start
of redemption at most it cannot be the
entire thing
because don't misunderstand me he does
the right thing
and he does it of his own accord and
that is a good thing
but anyone who has ever had to try and
come back from a string of bad choices
can tell you that you don't turn it
around at a stroke
forgive us somewhat clumsy analogy but
redeeming a character should be treated
the same as getting in shape
going for a jog once doesn't make you
fit
but it can be the start if you're
willing to put in the work
from here on out and maybe john walker
is but we don't know that yet and that
brings me to my last point
which is that he should not
have been granted the title of basically
backup captain america
now when i say he shouldn't have gotten
that
i don't mean that the writers screwed up
by doing it i mean that his getting
all but reinstated for one good thing
after a string of bad
felt to me at least like a fundamental
miscarriage of justice
especially in light of the fact that
isaiah bradley
who so far as we know never contravened
orders or broke rank
and only ever fought for his country was
hidden away and denied
any recognition for decades the fact
that happened to him but john walker
gets a fresh start
because he made the very obvious correct
choice in an either or scenario
feels absolutely wrong
and it's supposed to because he's a
white man in america whose priorities
are aligned with the status quo and
those in power
while isaiah bradley is a black man who
might make those in power look bad after
you know they did bad things and after
all this
if john walker celebrating becoming a us
agent felt like justice to you
then maybe at least think about the fact
that after railing against his superiors
for being what he made them i only ever
did what you
asked of me what you told me to be and
train me to do
and i did it he's perfectly happy to
leap right back into that roll
with a smile on his face for a woman he
doesn't even know
does that sound redeemed back
back back back does it even sound like
he learned a lesson all right
enough about that guy
[Music]
i've pretty much made my major points
but i just want to acknowledge some nice
touches and bits i liked that
didn't fit into what i decided to focus
on for the show overall
zemo's a ton of fun in the action scenes
madrapore is
stunningly realized and i cannot wait to
see it again
the fight on top of the trucks in
episode 2 was probably my favorite
action
scene in the show not only for being
cool as heck but for giving us a sense
of these characters both as individuals
and
as teams and partners i love the
emphasis on community and how sam is
able to bring together
everybody around him who will then help
him out
i love that by the end bucky feels like
a part of that same community
and appears willing to accept a place
there
i love the therapist just in general
she's great
ayo and the dora melange that's it just
the fact that they're here
and finally crowds cheering sam when he
shows up in full stars and stripes
is not only wonderful in and of itself
it reminds me of two of the best scenes
in sam raimi's spider-man films where
normal new yorkers had spidey's back
and that's never a bad thing to be
reminded of
[Music]
so that is the falcon and the winter
soldier a show
that not only wanted to be about
something it wore its intentions on its
sleeve from the very beginning and was
all the stronger for it now the show's
not perfect
but by and large when things didn't
totally work for me it was in small ways
moment-to-moment bits that maybe didn't
land or felt a little drawn out
but none of that ever tarnished the
strong theming at the heart
of this show when a piece of art knows
what it's about
and never loses sight of it it makes it
easier to appreciate as a whole
and i for one appreciate the heck out of
this show
thank you so much for listening if you
want to support what i do i have a
patreon and that is what enables this to
in fact
be my living and keep the whole thing
going there are
perks for every tier of support from
access to a patreon exclusive discord to
your name and the credits
and more but don't worry too much about
that because if you're not able to
support me that way
there is also the option for youtube
memberships but even just the likes the
shares and subscribes
also help me out quite a bit but also
i'm not even gonna put pressure on you
for that because
at the end of the day you are the
council i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
now
[Music]
you